you know i i'm a banker for 27 years i
never in a million years thought i would
have a non-profit but when my five kids
arrived from foster care all carrying a
trash bag i thought this is not the way
life is supposed to go
[Music]
can you believe it i'm still here that's
right living in this room for 100 days
from november 20th to february 28th
bring to you the awareness that you need
to know about the violence on the south
side of chicago but also to raise as
much money as possible to build a
community center on this much needed
block called oh block it's called o
block because it's named after a young
man named od perry who was shot and
killed the gangs took the o in his name
and start calling it o block we decided
we like the o but we're going to change
it to opportunity block i want to thank
fox for giving me the opportunity every
single day to bring to you rooftop
revelations where i share with you my
thoughts viewpoints and opinions and
every now and then i get to share with
you some very special guests and today
i'm really excited to have a special
guest with us tonight who's staying on
the roof robert shear from comfort cases
welcome all the way from new york yeah
thank you so much actually i actually
come from dc dc and so i cannot thank
you enough you know for me as a kid i
grew up on the streets um actually lived
on the streets when i was 18 my whole
senior year of high school so to be back
here pastor brooks um a little bit of
pts my friend
well we're gonna help you get through it
we're gonna have to get through it you
know i always start off like this
um
and ask all our guests what
brings you here on the south side of
chicago on this rooftop on a cold night
like tonight well you know first of all
everybody has to know something um our
community is not our zip code and you
gotta stop that we all have to stop that
our community is our human race
and what affects people right here on
the o block affects people in dc and
austin texas and seattle and if we do
not come together for change change will
never happen absolutely absolutely and
that's the reason why we're here that's
that's we're sharing community tonight
you know i want some tell us about your
story how you know how to comfort cases
i want everybody across the world to
know about comfort cases and how they're
helping project good but tell us about
comfort k you know for me you know i'm a
banker for 27 years i never in a million
years thought i would have a non-profit
but when my five kids arrived from
foster care all carrying a trash bag i
thought this is not the way life was
supposed to go and i remember back in
the day when i carried a trash bag in
foster care and how i had aged out and
became homeless and how you know the
statistics show that only 54 of kids in
foster care graduate from high school
but the saddest part for me was to hear
the fact that over 80 percent of our
prison inmates were from foster care and
i felt like i had to do something about
it so ten years ago my family and i
decided to put some cases together brand
new pajamas toothbrush toothpaste all
the essentials that a child needs on
their first night of foster care and
started handing them out that's works i
will tell you we thought we'd do five
ten but in the last ten years we've
delivered over 165 000 cases to all 50
states dc puerto rico and the united
kingdom and by the way my friend we have
them right here that's right we're going
to do it here on chicago tomorrow that's
exactly exciting about that you know
you said something about um
the prisons
and
kids being in foster care
a lot of the work that we do here at
project hood is targeted toward
individuals who
[Music]
who are
underserved or who are in dire need of a
lot of help can you just explain why
this is why it's so important for
organizations like project hood and
comfort cases to get involved in the
lives of these young people well you
know first of all we all have to
understand these kids do not belong to
you yeah they do not belong to me they
belong to us
to us
and if we do not change their future
today
i'll change your future tomorrow right
and the reason i'm going to take your
tax money i'm going to build another
prison when you look at the fact that we
have 438 000 kids in foster care and by
the way you want to talk about the gang
violence on this street
let's talk about the fact that 91
of the gang members have been touched
or in foster care wow you show me where
we have failed as a country you showed
me what are we doing for our future for
tomorrow you know i think about it every
day i'm the youngest of 10 kids 10
my brothers and sisters
teenage pregnancy suicide rate drug
overduction
overdose
prison
that's the path that we give kids in
foster care we got to change it and by
giving and donating and by the way for
all of you that follow me for all of you
that have heard me talk about it i say
this all the time there is enough money
to go around
project hood is where your dollars need
to go
right now and let me tell you why
we build this center today
we build another one tomorrow exactly
and another one that yesterday yes and
that's what we have to realize is
supposed to happen absolutely i'm trying
to be like comfort cases i'm trying to
go to every place that there's a need
and reach everyone everywhere because
that's really what community is really
all about and i tell you
we've been blessed as an organization to
have this platform that fox has given us
and so many people from around the
country have
helped us tremendously and i think when
you say community i think about that i
think about how all these people from
all over the country have come together
to be supportive not of just our pro our
not-for-profit but of yours as well and
before we go today i want to just ask
you this question
from your standpoint what is it going to
take for us
to turn this around as it relates to
games
foster care with children all of these
social ills we have going on
what is it going to take for us to turn
around you know i i don't want to be
cliche about this but i'm going to tell
you something you have to remember why
our forefathers built community yeah why
one reason
take care of each other
we have forgotten that along the way my
friend we have forgotten how important
it is right that when i lift you up
i stand taller absolutely and when you
lift me up
we stand taller together
well that's what it's really all about
and hopefully together we can make the
world a better place i agree especially
our great country listen i am going to
enjoy the conversation with my friends
at night uh talking about comfort cases
and all the wonderful work that they do
i want to thank you for continuing to
watch rooftop revelations every single
day
thank you fox for giving me this
opportunity and this platform
shouts out to eli steele for producing
such a great show and terrell for doing
all the film work
all of you every single day who tune in
i want to say thank you as usual and i
also want to say as always god bless you
god bless america and until tomorrow
another rooftop revelations
peace
you